this week on conflict zone at least 27
migrants perish in the english channel
will this now force europe to commit to
safer migration policies i hope it is a
catalyst finally give a half start in
brussels member of the european
parliament and the former prime minister
of belgium if eu member countries can't
agree on a life and death issue like
this what's the point of the eu only on
the eu level you can manage this as
polish security inflict water cannon and
tear gas on refugees at their border
with belarus what happened to the eu's
much vaunted values and what reforms are
needed also the trouble with facebook
and the need for a revamped nato all on
conflict zone
[Music]
geva hofstadt welcome to conflict zone
let's talk first about the migrants who
drowned last week since that's the
crisis of the moment
do you think this is going to be the
catalyst for some new european policies
on migration
i hope so because this tragedy in the in
the north sea
is not uh not the first tragedy and we
have seen so many uh casualties uh
tragedies in the mediterranean uh now
this is happening uh uh
in on the north sea so i i hope it is a
catalyst finally to have a common
european
migration policy
because it's already more than 20 years
that we are talking about a common
migration policy
and it never happened because a common
migration policy
could avoid
the tragedies as we have seen
last week
france called for urgent talks to
discuss this tragedy but then it
disinvited a british minister because he
didn't like one of boris johnson's
tweets you don't do that if you're
serious about finding solutions do you
i i don't think that you you you start
to do uh such talks with with with
tweets and that's maybe the way trump
did his policies but that's not the way
we do it uh inside the
european uh inside the european union so
uh i think more important is to
concentrate ourselves on what could
avoid such tragedies and again there
a change
in the european uh migration and asylum
policy is absolutely key
like there is also uh a need for the uk
for the united kingdom to understand
that they are now out of the european
union and they need to take their own
responsibility for their migration and
asylum policy yeah but i think i think
they understand that i think i i think
they understand that i'm talking about
diplomatic ground i hope so i'm not sure
i'm not so sure that maybe you
understand that i'm not sure that uh uh
that the british government and boris
johnson understand but this this
diplomatic standoff may be great fun for
governments but the only people who are
going to get hurt by this are the
migrants isn't it time for everyone to
stop playing games with these people's
lives
it's it's at the time now uh to do uh
what uh most governments especially also
the british government but also other
governments have always avoided to do
that is to develop a common uh migration
and asylum policy that is based not on
unanimity uh ruling on on a decision by
unanimity but on qualified majority
because that's the reason that we don't
have uh the last 20 years a common
migration and asylum policy it is
already since 1999
that we decided that migration would be
a common policy in the union and since
then nothing have happened and the the
first thing to do is to uh create uh and
to establish a common legal migration uh
policy because many of these tragedies
are uh the
the consequence of the fact that we
don't have a legal migration policy in
the union and the second thing to do is
to have common asylum standards in the
union so there is no shopping anymore
possible and the third thing to do is to
really better manage our outside borders
of the union uh the outside borders of
the union yeah and unfortunately i want
to come on to the outside borders in a
minute but if if if if eu member
countries can't agree on a life and
death issue like this what's the point
of the eu
the point of the eu is that only on the
eu level you can manage this you see
that with britain britain cannot manage
this alone it needs to ask to the
european union to take action otherwise
tragedies will continue tragedies for
people want to reach and want to go to
the united kingdom and the point is our
point is as you as the european
parliament we have already said for
years and i hope that in the next
conference on the future of europe we
will achieve that that we need to get
rid of the anonymity the problem is that
the fact that you need the approval of
27 member states before you can act and
in the in the meanwhile such strategies
are happening because of this
impossibility uh to go forward on
migration policy because the unanimity
uh requirement that uh uh that exists
today okay but at the same time that's
why this is going on
it's
it's not the only field
the eu is facing a major credibility
issue because it doesn't just sell goods
around the world it tries to sell values
as well and i'm wondering which values
the eu was selling when poland was
filmed tear gassing helpless migrants on
the border with belarus and showering
them with water cannon in freezing
temperatures not the greatest
advert for eu values was it doesn't
doesn't that make you sorry
no
now you're
now you're not very objective in the way
you put your question because the
problems at the police border are not a
problem caused by the european union or
caused by poland that are problems
caused by lukachenko
by belarus
do you think this was an appropriate way
to treat the migrants
and abuse uh migrants
well and they got abused by pisces again
that's a problem that has been
that it's a problem caused by lukachenko
so it's not very objective to inverse
the roles and to do as the migrants on
the border between belarus and poland
are a problem that has been caused uh by
the european union that's not and you
know it very well it's and and what we
have done uh in in the meanwhile is to
try to have agreements
with those countries where these people
come from uh so to avoid that are abused
by a dictatorship uh in the neighborhood
of the european union as has been the
case uh the last week and months and you
are right uh i deplore as you uh the use
of violence in death so so some of the
ideals
some of the deals that you've entered
into have resulted and i'm talking about
the particularly dirty deal with the
libyan coast guard paid in effect now by
the eu to hunt down migrant boats in the
mediterranean and take the people back
where there are human rights violations
are there's visited on them
continue i have to i have to tell you
one thing it may be your next time you
don't invite me to have your interview
you invite the commissioner who is
responsible for that because exactly as
a member of parliament i have criticized
this towards the european commission i'm
not
the
member of parliament who have defended
the policies of the european union so
next time you take european commissioner
responsible for these matters and you
ask him these questions i'm
as critical as you on the fact that it's
happening and there's a reason why i
think that european migration and asylum
policy needs to become a european union
matter what it is not today because all
elements that you have put forward the
problems in the naughty and the tragedy
we have seen in the naughty the problems
at the border between poland and belarus
the problems in the mediterranean uh
towards uh
uh libya and people coming from there
and abuse there are all the consequences
of the fact that our member states are
responsible for that and the european
union is not so it's not a question of
the european union it's a question of a
lack of european union a lack of
european migration and asylum policy but
next time my proposal to you is invite
the commissioner responsible for it
because i am as critical
towards what is happening in the
mediterranean and in the north sea as
you do you're critical about it the
media is critical about it the reports
have been coming in and going to the un
and human rights organizations for a
long time and yet nothing gets done
about it why do you think that is
because like i i will explain for a
third time of a fourth time now that
these policies for the moment are still
policies of the member states because
there is no unanimity inside european
council to change this migration
policies even at the moment when so many
people uh refugees came from yeah syria
and the conflict in syria towards europe
yeah
mrs merkel said okay we are schaffendas
we're gonna pick them we're going to
take them
inside germany that was a national
measure without consultation with the
others so we need absolutely a radical
change in the way european migration and
asylum policy is treated in the union
and we have to do it in a common way we
have to do it on the european level with
a good border management with common
asylum and migration conditions and with
a legal migration part we because a lot
of the tragedies uh in the mediterranean
and in the nazi are the consequence of
the absence today of a legal way to come
to work to be active
as a migrant in europe
you claimed earlier this year that eu
integration has been enormously
important you said to enshrine rules
rights and freedoms into our societies
in europe but in a number of eu
countries those rules exist only on
paper don't they and you're powerless as
you said to do anything about that
hungary and poland for instance with all
the rule of law issues they know how to
game the system don't they and they can
paralyze it if they want to hold up
discussions on the budget hold up this
and that so far from enshrining your
rules the eu is being strangled by them
isn't it
no absolutely not there is a way to
tackle this but there is an
unwillingness uh in the european council
under the heads of states and government
and under the prime ministers to tackle
that problem what i expect is that with
the new german government arriving
a government of socialist liberals and
greens
that this new government will be far
more critical on this issue let's be
honest about it until now we didn't
tackle the problem in hungary we didn't
tackle in in poland because the european
council under the leadership of mrs
merkel was not capable to do it the
power you said they were gathering
you said they were guthrie
sorry the commission launched the
procedure on it and the european court
of justice also took its responsibility
the only institution would didn't take
its responsibility was the european
council and i i think
my expectation is that with new german
government arriving in power now this
will change and we will see a really
european union who is active using the
instruments uh to make sure
that the values in the european union
also applied in countries like poland
and hungary you've criticized european
leaders for lack of courage you said the
the instruments for instance with uh for
dealing with rule of law issues in
hungary existed the instruments exist
you said only the courage among leaders
is failing so why do you think eu
leaders are so gutless on this issue
for the simple reason that in the
council everything is decided between
them i have never seen an european
council and i was a long time a member
of the european council one colleague
attacking another colleague one
colleague criticizing another colleague
one colleague sanctioning i should say
another colleague around the table that
doesn't help that doesn't work in
european council therefore i think uh
with the arrival of new german
government i think that we will see
european council far more critical
towards what is happening in poland and
in hungary and on top of that i think
that in the future
we need maybe to change the instruments
and change the instruments that means to
give to the european court of justice
the capability the competence not only
to give judgments about what is
happening in poland and hungary but also
to decide on sanctions
what is the case in every normal
rule of law system
in every country so i think that
fundamentally and ultimately it will be
necessary to give a new competence to
the european court of justice but to
give them the possibility uh to decide
on sanctions towards countries that are
not applying the fundamental values of
the union you mentioned earlier the
conference on the future of europe which
you're co-chairing
yet another inquiry into what europeans
want from their institutions
has there ever been an organization that
did so much
naval gazing and introspection
no it's not it's it's not uh consulting
what they want it's absolutely not that
while we are organizing with a
conference on the future of europe is an
unseen exercise where we try to combine
representative democracy with
participatory democracy these citizens
what you're talking about in totally 800
selected randomly selected people are
not
are not there to give their opinion
and it's over no no they are
participating in the decision-making
process it's for the first time uh i
think in in a modern democracy that
citizens are directly involved in the
decision-making process that is what we
are doing
not many of them
the numbers taking down
there are for the moment four million
people
who are on the platform who have uh got
access to the digital platform the
conference on the future of europe there
are 10 and 10 or several tens of
thousands war on daily basis debating on
the future of uh the european union and
in top of that there have been in a
scientific way 800 people selected and
all these people have nothing to do with
the european union to participate in the
decision-making process we have seen
such uh
yeah what we call citizens convention
already in france already in ireland
already in germany but it's for the
first time that it is organized on a
pan-european level and my expectation of
this exercise is not to listen to the
citizens because we know what the
citizens want we have the euro barometer
we have surveys like this is the case
also in britain no the big difference is
that these citizens or who are selected
will continue to participate in not only
formulating recommendations but also in
the answers the
politicians will give to their wishes
and
to the recommendations
you said to regain people's trust in
democracy we need to fundamentally
revisit the way our democracies work so
they are for and with the people
instead of that why not concentrate on
results
find a way for 27 disparate countries to
pull together on the major problems that
are facing them something that they have
conspicuously failed to do so far
well
for the simple reason that uh the the
pressure that can be created by a
participation of the citizens will be so
huge
that i am i am confident that we can
find two ways to break the resistance uh
of of some member states to go forward
uh inside the european union we need the
power of the people we need the power of
the citizens inside this conference to
go through barriers for example the
barrier of unanimity and secondly yeah
we need is also this new type of
democracy because our liberal democracy
your liberal democracy our liberal
democracy is under threat today under
threat from outside european union china
russia but also under threat inside
because of the social media social media
like facebook are undermining our
liberal democracy so a direct
involvement of the citizens
inside the decision-making process of
the european union is really the good
answer i think a real answer towards uh
yeah this degrading liberal democracy
through the social media as we see it
today why why is facebook undermining
your liberal democracy why
is that
is that
i i think that that's obvious at least
everybody understands that when you go
on facebook and you put i don't know
what uh for example chinese communist
party uh on on your facebook that for
the next five or ten years you will
receive
mostly only uh posts and see posts and
and messages concerning the chinese
communist party well if that's the only
thing you put in yes but if you put in a
whole range of other things you'll get
some references to them too explain
sorry let me explain
the algorithms behind
the the system of facebook are made in
such a way that at the end people only
see
what they think
and not the counter argument and that's
a very good model to make profits in the
in the us maybe in the united states but
it's a very bad model for the pluralism
in our liberal democracies let's come
back to the eu um the question is is
often raised about accountability among
the commission
do you believe that this commission is
accountable how many of its
commissioners ever get sacked once in
its history once since 1958
is there accountability in the
commission
no that's not that's not true that's not
true what you're saying you're you're
you or forgot the to mention the fact
that uh this parliament at a certain
moment has dismissed and
and put home a whole commission uh uh
once and also a commission uh president
uh in in in in in the past uh that's not
true so there have been many examples of
uh of that but it's true
that we need to increase the power of
this european parliament to make it a
real european democracy and the power
the additional power that this european
parliament needs is power and taxation
that is something we are missing uh for
at the moment and the second thing what
we need is the right of initiative for
this european parliament to initiate new
uh proposals so if you tell me that
there is not enough power for european
parliament in controlling the commission
and in controlling the council and in
developing a number of policies you're
right yes
we talked earlier about what you called
failing courage among europe's leaders
in 2018 you went further and you said
the union tends to be rather weak in the
face of global challenges that was
pretty much the case wasn't it when
donald trump was president allowing
europe to be lectured like naughty
school children about nato funding and
who you could trade with and who you
couldn't pretty degrading wasn't it yeah
but yeah but it's it it didn't
fundamentally change with biden biden or
trump both are uh criticizing the
european union for that and for good
reasons not because there is not
sufficient funding but because there is
not sufficient cooperation inside europe
you know that europe is spending is
spending more than china on on military
expenditures we are spending in europe
without even the uk
four times more than the russians on
military the problem of military in
europe is not the level of spending the
problem is that we do it 28 times 27
times now after the brexit and that we
duplicate everything 27 times we spend
more or less 35 percent of the americans
and military and we can only do 10
of the operations of the american army
what does it mean if you spend 25
percent of the americans and can only do
10 of the operations that you're three
to four times less effective and that's
the consequence of duplication so my
plea is that the fastest as possible
will create this european defense
community as a pillar of nato the
european pillar of nato and that's the
real answer to our geopolitical weakness
and not spend a little bit more of tax
money as we do to it today
but do you agree that one of the
commissioners thierry breton said the
other day that something is broken in
transatlantic relations and that's
neither a reference to trump nor biden
is is there something that he was
talking about temporary or is the
transatlantic alliance coming unstuck
irrespective of who's in the white house
no no what what what i see is the
absolutely need for a reform of the
north atlantic alliance
and why i'm saying that when
joe biden is coming a few weeks ago to
europe to the nato summit he's talking
about china he's talking about china
that is in the south pacific no that's
not the north atlantic that means that
our defense issues today are not related
only to
the environment in the north atlantic
but are worldwide and that there is a
need to reform the nato into a global
world alliance of democracies
and that on a continental scale that
means that
the north american continent the asian
continent european continent has to do a
real effort to create defense
communities to defend our liberal uh
democracies so the nato is today still
an alliance of individual countries and
what i think is that we need to trans to
transform it into a real alliance of uh
continental defense communities
defending liberal democracy you want to
reform nato you want to reform rules
inside the european union you want to
change the unanimity rule you want a lot
of reforms and you want a federal a
federal europe at the end of it a sort
of one size fits all it's what if you
don't get any of these reforms that's
absolutely not true it's the eu because
uh that
so you you have a complete
misunderstanding of what federalism is
because a one fit for all that's not the
federalism that's the opposite it's the
opposite you see it in the united states
of america united states of america or
50 states with 50 different
constitutions with 50 different armies
and so on and so on so when i am i'm a
federalist that's true but federalist
for me means that everything what you
can do on the local level you know on
the local level what you can better do
on a national level would you do better
on the national level but where there is
an added value on the european level
that you have to do on the european
level and it's the only way for the
europeans
to defend our interests or values on in
the new world order that is emerging
today is emerging no it exists already
today there will be a time where it will
be the chinese we will be decide on our
standards we will be decide on our way
of life and the only way to counter that
is to organize
a federal democratic
uh in diversity european continental
european union kieva hofstadt it's been
good to have you on conflict zone thank
you very much
so
you